the most epic Fight Continues as the
strongest and tameless shikigami
mahoraga enters the ring Limitless Gojo
reaches his limit but they're even more
crazy twists after that so make sure
stay tuned for this one smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing these Jujutsu
Kaizen reviews on the channel and want
to keep them coming place your bets for
who you think is gonna win right now in
the comments Gojo or sukunan you'll have
bragging rights for life and lastly make
this the video you joined the fan by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell if you haven't already
so you don't miss future Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen updates and now without further
Ado let's jump to the main event of Main
Events spoilers and all so as we saw
maharaga AKA destruction incarnate as
the narrator calls him has entered the
ring this chapter is called the decisive
battle in the uninhabited demon-infested
Shinjuku part 8. and not gonna lie I
always kind of thought it was cool that
this mangaka could get away with not
worrying about titles for so many
chapters like this by just counting up
until he's done with whatever is
happening I personally haven't seen that
often but respect and in my lifetime I
had to come up with many any titles for
essays and videos so I can just say it's
nice when you don't have to so it's
pointed out that as we know mahoraga is
the Crown Jewel of the zening clan and
that it's a shikigami with the ability
to adapt to any attack and Yuji for his
part is shocked by the possibility that
it was even able to adapt to goju's
unlimited void we get some beautiful
panels giving us a sense of a shortcom
before the storm continues we see how
big the shikigami is and even the edges
can't contain him I love that detail I
also gotta say in the middle of this
fight I love how the mangaka takes the
time to even illustrate the birds flying
overhead in an artistic way not expected
but definitely appreciated we're told
Gojo was well aware of maharaga's
abilities in his battle with yorozu
sukuna used mahuraga's adaptation
ability for himself in order to see
through her construction technique
there's definitely quite a bit of
explaining and text going on in this
chapter but it's okay because it's in a
cool way like in Death Note so it works
with that in mind we're told the domain
expansions sure hit effects canceled
each other out a total of 5 times Gojo
sure hit effect targeted everything
within the domain and tsukunas targeted
everything within the domain except
himself which meant that the sure hit
effect targeting tsukuna was still in
place you gotta respect How Deep The
mangaka goes with these fighting
mechanics tsukuna continued to take on
unlimited void five times all while
shouldering the burden of maharaga's
adaptation and the one who actually bore
this burden was and it's Gojo that tells
us it was megumi's Soul he is the one
taking the damage to use the adaptation
even Gojo is shocked and impressed which
is the best thing about this fight since
he's usually so confident and you gotta
appreciate the small talk and the trash
talk between these two overconfident
Legends tsukuna says you look like you
have something on your mind as he sees
Gojo trying to wrap his head around what
happened and goju responds not really it
just warms my heart seeing you so
desperate I personally can't help but
laugh and enjoy these back and forths
even tsukuna laughs saying look who's
talking tsukuna explains confidently
that he knew unlimited void would be a
real pain that's why his first move was
to take that card out of of the deck as
mentioned he had megumi adapt to
unlimited void using his 10 Shadows
technique as a result sukuna couldn't
use any cursed technique other than what
was imbued to his domain and he supposes
that paid off in its own way Gojo for
his part says megumi just took on the
process of adaptation not the resulting
adaptation so sukuna hasn't actually
adapted megumi's Soul itself to
unlimited void if he opens his domain
expansion again maharaga won't be able
to bail sukuna out because Gojo will
destroy it in one attack he says now
let's appreciate how hype and confident
Gojo is here it looks like he's about to
win but then we see sukuna and he just
laps in a Carefree way he simply tells
him that Gojo can no longer use his
domain and he turns out to be right
Gojo's domain isn't launched instead
blood floods from his nose and our
viewers are understandably shocked and
worried to see this even though it was
hinted at earlier if you recall the
smaller nosebleed earlier that Yuta took
note of it's explained find that using
reverse curse technique to heal your
exhausted innate technique strains you
on a whole other level compared to
normal reverse curse technique healing
as tsukuna explains curse technique is
etched into your brain roughly around
your right prefrontal cortex Gojo has
been using his cursed energy to damage
his own brain and then using reverse
curse technique to refresh the burnt out
technique Yuta screams that even using
that once is way too risky we're told
the brain and especially the part where
curse techniques are concerned is a
black box and props to this manga for
teaching me new things a black box
apparently in computer science is a
system that operates as we have no
knowledge of its internal workings in
other words it's a lot more dangerous
and complicated to mess with than just
thinking about healing and doing it
chosu says based on that Gojo should
already be at death's door as brother
Yuji points out that he's done it five
times already shoko points out something
interesting saying that she thought Gojo
had been getting used to Healing his
brain in that definitely what it seemed
like from the outside since we always
like to think of Gojo as Untouchable but
now it seems to her that he's suffering
the sequelae another thing I learned
thanks to this chapter thank you Jujutsu
Kaiser the word in medicine means a
condition which is the consequence of a
previous disease or injury in other
words Gojo's previous damaging of his
brain over and over again is catching up
with him now it doesn't just fully heal
every time he uses healing shoko says
sukun has done it fewer times and so he
has more leeway than Gojo here sukuna
chimes in as gojus on his knee now
saying you've reached a limit completely
separate from healing your Flesh and
Bones he goes so far as to say that if
Gojo could expand his domain again he'd
perish the moment he did and on top of
that he wouldn't be precise enough to
oppose sukuna just as moments ago Gojo
seemed in control now sukuna seems in
control by a mile but what's an epic
battle like this without even more
twists and turns as sukuna is hyping
himself up on and on saying he's going
to do this and that going to close the
barrier of his domain so Gojo can't run
going to carve Gojo into pieces and even
adapt to his infinity and says this is
goodbye and that Gojo was born in an era
without sukuna and hail to be the
strongest and yet turned out to be so
ordinary my point is he just keeps going
and going but when it comes down to it
and he activates his domain expansion he
himself starts bleeding and it's even
worse than Gojo not just from the nose
but from the eyes as well the narrator
lets us know that it hadn't even been 10
seconds since sukuna took a blow from
unlimited void and yet just like Gojo
sukuna's brain sustained enough damage
to make domain expansion impossible and
now just like that Gojo is the one
laughing in an over the top way like the
Joker saying looks like it's hitting you
pretty damn hard he says his students
are watching so he's going to keep
showing off props the sukuna too he's
still smiling himself despite how
damaged he looks now after the domain
expansions have been exhausted at least
for now we jump into a fist fight and
and Gojo gets such a satisfying punch in
but keep in mind we see the shikigami's
wheel spinning so we'll see sukuna
drawing on his adaptation Powers as well
and after the punch ironically sukuna's
eyes look recovered compared to moments
before they are both smiling and we're
told neither yields the decisive battle
of the strongest heads to round two love
to hear that because it sounds like
we'll be getting a lot more awesomeness
and there's no fight more hype we're
also told the loneliness that comes with
unrivaled strength the one who will
teach you about love is and that's where
it cuts off interesting to mention love
here we'll see what that's going to be
about let me know if you have any
theories in the comments but the
loneliness that comes with unrivaled
strength is a good line we should keep
in mind that for Gojo finally he has a
challenge and so that loneliness is gone
for once you can bet he's enjoying this
challenge at least in that regard
another amazing chapter of this epic
fight don't forget to place your bets on
who's winning in the comments and if you
can't get enough of strong characters
like me then be sure to check out our
special grade sorcers and their powers
explained video where we discuss the
strongest of the strong link on screen
right now and I'll see you there